hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown with the first
two nights of their convention in the
books republicans have two more nights
to lay out their message
will the gop's approach be enough to
convince the american people
that president trump deserves another
four years fox news radio's national
correspondent jared halpern
and fox news radio's political analyst
josh kraushauer recapped the major
moments
with mark lotter director of strategic
communications for the trump 2020
campaign
and the trump administration is granted
the emergency authorization
of convalescent plasma to treat
hospitalized covid19 patients
however some top health officials argue
data from clinical trials
are too weak to support widespread use
health and human services secretary alex
azar
and dennis zembauer a coronavirus
survivor who recently received blood
plasma
shared their thoughts on the treatment
plus commentary by fox news
correspondent at large
geraldo rivera the fox news rundown is a
daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com i'm
sandra smith i'm brett baer i'm ainsly
earhart and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday august 26 2020
i'm jared halpern the first family took
center stage on night two
of the republican national convention
we're going to be very involved in
making sure that we elect not only a
republican majority of the senate
but overtaking the democrats in the
house
i'm jessica rosenthal broader use of
convalescent plasma has been approved by
the fda to help treat
kovid even though there are some
skeptics we are in an unprecedented
pandemic and president trump is going to
ensure that we
get rid of any unnecessary bureaucratic
red tape that stands in the way of
saving lives
and i'm geraldo rivera i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
the people closest to president trump
made their case for giving him
four more years the second night of the
republican national convention
featured two of the president's adult
children daughter tiffany trump
we believe in equality of opportunity
we believe in freedom of thought and
expression
think what you want seek out the truth
and son
eric trump every day my father fights
for the american people
the forgotten man and woman of this
country
the ones who embody the american spirit
which is unlike anything else in the
world
the night was capped with a live rose
garden speech from the first lady
melania trump
who opened her remarks speaking about
two of the biggest news stories in the
nation right now
the coronavirus pandemic i want to
acknowledge the fact
that since march our lives have changed
drastically the invisible enemy
covered 19 swept across our beautiful
country
and impacted all of us
my deepest sympathy goes out to everyone
who has lost a loved one and my prayers
are with those
who are ill or suffering and protest
sometimes turning violent about racial
injustice
like all of you i have reflected on the
racial unrest
in our country it is a harsh reality
that we are not proud of parts of our
history
i encourage people to focus on our
future
while still learning from our past as
has been the case for both knights of
the republican convention president
trump had some surprise appearances as
well
tuesday night highlighting official
actions as president
in one video president trump granted a
full presidential pardon to john ponder
a convicted bank robber who after prison
created a nonprofit
hope for prisoners president trump
called ponder's story
a beautiful testament to the power of
redemption
we believe that each person is made by
god for a purpose
i will continue to give all americans
including former inmates
the best chance to build a new life and
achieve their own
american dream and a great american
dream it is
later in the evening another white house
event a naturalization ceremony for
five new u.s citizens sworn in by the
acting homeland security secretary
chad wolfe i take this obligation freely
that i take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation
without any
mental health or purpose of evasion
so help me god congratulations you're
now
citizens of the united the president
using the event to praise legal
immigration
you followed the rules you obeyed the
laws you learned your history
embraced our values and proved
yourselves to be
men and women of the highest integrity
both events drew immediate criticism
from some government watchdog groups who
say using the white house for political
purposes undermines
the hatch act which prohibits federal
employees from taking part in political
activity while in
government buildings or on official duty
it does not apply to the president or
the vice president
but a house panel has already announced
an investigation
in the secretary of state mike pompeo's
participation
in the convention tuesday night what you
saw was the
the embodiment of america being a land
of opportunity
mark lotter is the director of strategic
communications for the trump campaign
he joined me and fox news radio
political analyst josh crossout whether
it was
the president clearing the crime
obviously
of someone who has gone on to do so many
great things that helps so many
other people who are coming out of our
of our prison system and then welcoming
in
you know five new citizens to the united
states it just shows
that we are that land of hope and
opportunity uh which we've been talking
about for a while
and it's in direct contrast to the doom
and gloom we saw from the democrats last
week can i
ask about your response to some of the
criticism that this was
an inappropriate use of the office of
the presidency that's the to use
you know these official events you know
i i think the american people are smart
enough to
to figure out that our presidents
regardless of party
are are elected through a political
system
and you know presidents have been using
air force one as a backdrop for
for decades now and i think they're
smart enough to realize
that you know that when you see
something like this as part of
the republican national uh convention in
the middle of a
of an election season uh that you you
see
a politician who's making a case for
himself to be reelected
uh and obviously from a technical
standpoint the hatchet doesn't apply to
the president or the vice president so
you know it's really just kind of
washington
you know over reacting to uh to things
that
i don't believe most america really just
cares about
hey mark i want to talk about the the
naturalization ceremony as well and
the political uh goal of having that
front and center
tonight you know the trump brand has
largely been
connected to you know building the wall
of being tough on
illegal immigration you know he's he's
he's cut the number of refugees
in his in his tenure that are coming to
this country from other
other countries you know that's been the
trump brand this was a different side of
trump uh
trying to show that he's compassionate
to legal immigrants but
you know what's the what's the political
sweet spot which side of the president
do you want to show
to republican and independent voters at
this convention
well i think we want to show both uh
because i i believe
you know the president has been very
consistent in in
in saying he supports both that yes we
have to stop illegal immigration
but that we are a country of immigrants
and that for folks who are coming in and
doing it the right way
waiting in line going through that
process and you know
that is something we have to have and
you know if you if you go back to
obviously prior to covet we had more job
openings than we did
unemployed people and that wasn't going
to stop and the president was very clear
saying
we need more immigrants to come in and
help steal some of these positions
but we want the best we want the
brightest regardless of where
you come from we just want you to make
sure that you can come here and
contribute
to our country in a legal fashion
and i think that was again very much a a
a personification an
embodiment of what the president has
been saying for a while
but you know mark that there are parts
members of this administration
that haven't just talked about cracking
down on illegal immigration
there have been proposals uh that have
talked about cutting
certain types of legal immigration is
that is that no longer
politically the message that this
convention wants to send to
the country well the president has been
very clear in that he wants to overhaul
our immigration system where we have an
immigration system based on merit
and even in our legal immigration system
there are holes there are loopholes
there are gaps where you have thing
where where you are bringing in people
who are not necessarily
coming in based on what they can
contribute to our country
but basically what their relation is to
someone who may or may not even be here
legally so what the president has said
is that he wants to follow the model of
canada of australia of so many other
countries
that actually award their immigration
process their citizenship
through merit and and so when we're
welcoming new citizens that like
the president did i think he's
celebrating the fact that we do have
people and you heard him highlight their
stories
about how they're adding to the fabric
of america contributing
and being productive members of society
one of the uh
speakers that will speak on wednesday
night night three of this convention is
joni ernst obviously the senator from
iowa who's facing a pretty tough
re-election bid if you look at the the
way that that race is shaping up mark
i'm curious
as this convention moves forward and as
this campaign
moves forward what is the president's
involvement in some of these down ballot
races trying to keep control of the
senate trying to win back the house
well i think you'll see the president
very involved obviously our you know our
campaign is focused on you know those
battleground states that will put him
above 270.
things are looking very good right now
and in areas where
we have a competitive senate seat or we
have competitive house races
you'll absolutely see the president
involved you've seen him involved in the
primary
throughout but that's also where the
vice president plays a key role and i've
been traveling a lot obviously i
traveled throughout 16
and 18 with the vice president and he'll
go into many of those states as well
at a congressional district level for a
senate seat
uh that may or may not necessarily be in
a state that we have to absolutely
uh you know win or we already have we
believe we have secured at a statewide
level
so this is where the team comes into
play so much
we also have the the trump children that
can go out there but we're going to be
very involved in making sure that we
elect
not only a republican majority of the
senate but
overtaking the democrats in the house
you mentioned the vice president i know
you know the vice president very well
any preview about the remarks he'll make
wednesday night
well i think the vice president's going
to do exactly what he has been doing
already we saw it
in wisconsin here just in the last
couple of weeks in multiple trips to
wisconsin
where the vice president has highlighted
joe biden and the democrats failures in
terms of their record whether it's on
on support of nafta which joe biden
voted for
and his opposition to the usmca
those kinds of things where we're
actually starting to see
the positive impacts of what the
president has done
this is where the vice president has
been very much
bringing the facts to the case you'll
also see the vice president's optimism
he's a very optimistic person who
believes like the president that the
best of america is yet to come
mark lotter is the director of strategic
communications for the trump campaign
mark appreciate the time good luck as
this convention moves forward over the
next two nights
thank you for having me
this is geraldo rivera with your fox
news commentary
coming up just a couple of days before
president trump announced that
convalescent plasma would be used more
broadly to treat those with the virus he
blasted the fda
on twitter saying the deep state at the
fda is making it too difficult to test
vaccines and therapeutics
and plotting to delay until after the
election in november
just days prior to that there was a
report out that some doctors at the
national institute of health wanted to
slow down on the broader use of
convalescent plasma
saying the data wasn't strong enough but
sunday afternoon the president announced
the fda was giving an emergency use
authorization
for convalescent plasma to be given to
patients with covit to deliver
treatments and
vaccine to save lives we're removing
unnecessary barriers and delays
not by cutting corners but by marshaling
the full power of the federal government
and fda commissioner dr stephen hahn
hinted there was no
election motivated deep state delay
because of the president's operation
warp speed
we expect to have other new results and
new options reaching patients as soon as
this fall
operation warp speed is supporting
experimental therapeutics
all the way through to manufacturing so
that if they meet fda's gold standard
for safety and efficacy they can begin
reaching patients
without a day wasted han had said a
recent study showed convalescent plasma
reduced mortality by
35 percent but critics have cast doubt
on that study
and after he was accused of grossly
exaggerating the benefits
han admitted this week that he chose his
words poorly the study didn't have a
control group
the study sponsored by the mayo clinic
did find some statistically significant
benefit to convalescent plasma
it showed mortality for those getting
plasma within three days of being
diagnosed
was 8.7 percent but if someone was given
the plasma after four or more days
mortality was 11.9 percent
a similar percentage difference was
found between those given plasma
with higher rather than lower antibody
levels which is
of note when somebody gets coveted
and then recovers their body has
produced antibodies to the antigens
in the virus those antibodies are
present
in your plasma alex azar is the health
and human services secretary
you can donate plasma in a way similar
to donating blood at the american red
cross or your local blood bank
and that plasma contains your antibodies
and then those antibodies that plasma
can be given to somebody
who is suffering from covid and what we
have uh what we have done is uh made
that available
under president trump's right to try
initiative
to over 70 000 patients in the united
states
and the fda authorized its emergency use
for people who are suffering from covet
so it can it can reduce the severity
and reduce the likelihood of mortality
for individuals
um and we encourage anybody who has had
coveted and recovered
to go to coronavirus.gov to learn more
about how they can donate uh
or call their lo the american red cross
or their local blood bank
but talk to me about the successes that
we've seen
so far with those seventy thousand
people because it's you know
it has been reported i believe in the
new york times they said national
institutes of health director dr collins
and even dr
anthony fauci had tried to intervene
in a decision to allow convalescent
plasma use saying the data just wasn't
strong enough yet
um obviously that that's since changed
because it's now been approved
um but talk to me about what we do know
about the successes given
the reports that some people like uh you
know like fouchy and collins have said
wait a second maybe we shouldn't go
there just yet well what we did
is we had this expanded access program
under president trump's leadership of
right to try to make sure that people
would have this
convalescent plasma available and we
collected data on it
and importantly uh what what what having
that many people exposed to convalescent
plasma did
is we had everybody produces different
levels of antibodies
in their plasma and so when when they
donate you could have somebody with a
very high level of antibodies we call
that a high
titer or you could have a donation that
was a low
titer and what this enabled us to do was
to
actually study the impact of higher
levels of antibodies in the plasma
and it demonstrated clearly that the
higher levels of antibodies
administered to people who had not yet
but been put on any type of mechanical
respiration
who were under age 80 and were given
this
within three days of being admitted to
the hospital so earlier in their disease
progression
saw significant benefit now you still
are
we're still running the more traditional
clinical trials
where you test it against a placebo in a
randomized controlled clinical trial and
that's the
that's the kind of thing that we would
do for a normal full-on permanent
license of the product but this type of
large-scale statistical analysis
showed that that you have a dose
response we call it the higher titer
of antibodies leads to a better response
the earlier someone gets it
the better um we'll want to confirm all
of that as
you know nih and fda would like through
the the
randomized clinical trials but for an
emergency and this
unprecedented pandemic this is a very
accepted type of treatment
and now it has the authorization from
the
fda to go forward in all hospitals
secretary there have been plenty of
headlines about how you know the fda
authorized this use of plasma under
pressure you know the word pressure's
been applied in a lot of these headlines
um from the trump administration and the
president himself did tweet
um something about like the deep state
at the fda
is making it difficult um to get
vaccines and therapeutics and
that you know the the they're hoping to
delay everything until after the
election november third
can you comfortably say there is no
pressure to approve
plasma as a treatment so the
the we are in an unprecedented pandemic
and president trump is going to ensure
that we
get rid of any unnecessary bureaucratic
red tape that stands in the way of
saving lives
um this convalescent plasma data came in
over the course of the last week was
being analyzed by nih and fda
and actually uh as of friday we're
preparing roll out materials
for an authorization uh on sunday
so that was already well underway this
was as we said an independent
determination
by the center for biologics at the fda
the career top official
as well as commissioner han the
commissioner of food and drugs
and the fda is not delaying vaccines or
therapeutics until after the election
right
uh no no but what what what the
president is insisting on
what i insist on is that we move as
quickly as we can
to meet the fda's safety efficacy and
regulatory standards whether it's
therapeutics or vaccines and that's
really
what's behind operation warp speed is
how can we reduce any inefficiency
get rid of any unnecessary bureaucratic
red tape
to move with speed because people's
lives are at risk here this is a global
unprecedented pandemic
and we have got to move as quickly as
possible
our normal timelines just can't hold
they've
we've got to move fast the president
insists on that
but we're also going to insist that
products whether therapeutics or
vaccines
meet the fda standards of data and
evidence
uh to meet their regulatory requirements
so
many have already been given
convalescent plasma as part of a trial
including 68-year-old dennis zembauer
who lives in a rural part of
pennsylvania
he has an underlying health condition
that impacts his lungs
he got coveted earlier this month he
says he was careful and has no idea how
he got it
i started running a fever and i had
night sweats
like three three nights in a row or so
and i was running 101 and 102 fever
and i was dehydrating i started getting
the shakes
and uh dry eaves i mean i was really
weak i could tell i was getting dizzy
and i knew i
was getting dehydrated so i told my
fiance i said you're gonna have to
take me to the hospital so you
are you're 68 years old you have an
underlying health condition having to do
with your lungs it sounds like
um how scared were you
ah it scared me pretty good i mean that
with the other health issues i had and i
knew this
the way it did i mean it went straight
to my lungs right away
i got a lot of anxiety out of it i mean
when i went to the emergency room they
had nothing really set up for a tobit
patient so
they kind of put me in a small room by
myself
with some oxygen and they you know put
ivs and stuff on me to
uh bring my dehydration back to normal
so i can
get because i couldn't drink enough so
they put some fluids in me
when i was laying in there it just kind
of dawned on me that
yeah i'm hoping that i'm going to get
out of here i mean this
you know it scared me pretty good talk
to me about the
the course of treatment because you were
given a number of things and the reason
we're talking to you is because one of
the things you were given was
convalescent plasma
but you were also given room desevere it
sounds like you were given sort of a
cocktail
yeah when they they first came to me
with uh
the rendezvous and said you i guess it's
still experimental i don't know but
they asked if i wanted to try it i said
yes i said i'll do
i want to try anything to get rid of
this stuff i mean i
didn't want to spend any more time in
the hospital than i had to
and then when they they didn't i got one
of those and then there's a beer and
then they said about the convalescent uh
plasma i said yes i said i
i had worked in the medical field as an
emt
you know in my younger days back in the
70s and 80s
and i knew plasma was something that
it's not really going to hurt you
there's nothing really in it other than
antibodies and i said well
if that's if this is from a covid
patient and uh
they're experimenting on this to to use
their antibodies to help someone i said
yes i'll try it
so i signed up for a study so your
previous
sort of knowledge of what what plasma
even is is what made you feel
comfortable
yes yes now that the
fda has approved the um the eua the
emergency use authorization to give
people
this more broadly what do you think
would you tell another coveted patient
look just just try this i mean do you
think it's what
did it for you or do you think it's the
rem death severe or you just you don't
know
oh i don't know but i like i said that
once i heard that the president
they were pushing this and it was okay
yeah i would i would
tell anybody to yes go ahead and take
the plasma it is not going to hurt you
and i said if the antibodies in there
help you at all really it's it's worth
the
chance to take it and i told them i said
once i get over this
and i'm not sure how long they will let
you go here before you can
donate plasma but i told them i would
also donate plasma back to them
for a later date for someone else you
know if they need it
are you convinced that it helped in your
case
i i don't know but i would say i mean
with my improvement as fast as i did i
said it probably did help me some
i asked dennis since he's experienced
covid how he feels about the politics of
it all from his
swing state perch is he disappointed in
the handling of the virus from either
the president or pennsylvania's
democratic governor or health officials
i i don't think it's the politician's
fault i mean there
there's nothing uh i mean the president
tried to shut the country down right
away when he heard this was coming over
and i said the governor i mean a lot of
people
don't like him the way he's doing things
but dude
it's saying it's all it's all political
to slow things
down but i i don't know i don't really
believe all that because this
this uh is it's a serious disease
i mean they said that the people that
didn't get that sick on it think
there was nothing to it that the people
that really got sick on it
you ask them and they'll say you know if
there's a big difference here
i don't blame the politicians i'll know
it's the people need to
do their own thing here if you're not
afraid of it go do what you want to do
and
the ones you know take care of yourself
interesting
dennis zembauer i'm so glad i got to
speak to you thank you so much for your
time and
stay healthy thank you
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news
listen and download the fox news hourly
update on your time the trending stories
you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
geraldo
rivera what's on your mind there are
competing visions of america going on in
the two political conventions
the democrats last week seeing this more
or less as a referendum over donald
trump
especially his handling of the covet-19
crisis
did he do all he could have as soon as
he should have
in dealing with the plague republicans
this week
see it as society's last chance this
election
to protect itself against urban violence
and decay
law and order a black man was shot in
the midst of all this
his name jacob blake and he survived
surgery and is now in stable condition
after being shot seven times in the back
by cops
in kenosha wisconsin riots and arson
followed
as angry residents took the opportunity
to loot and
burn and scar their city shot by
cops jacob gets sympathy democratic
leaders
have yet to publicly show any victim of
black on black violence
which is far more prominent but that
doesn't matter
this was a deeply troubling event in a
thoughtful and understandably angry
statement
following the back shooting of jacob
blake by cops in kenosha
lebron james king james the basketball
superstar
said it shows why black people are
terrified of police
for black people right now we think you
are hunting us
isn't it sad ladies and gentlemen that
this has come to this
far more black people may be shot by
other black people than by cops
but that is no comfort there's no
denying that black men are treated much
more negatively
and have much more intensely negative
experiences
dealing with cops than white men do i
don't know why jacob blake was shot in
the back
but it stinks we wish him we miss the
victims of all this violence
a speedy recovery i'm gerald rivera
reporting
fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes